the movie starts in a peaceful Suburban
neighborhood where all of a sudden a
young girl starts running she
continuously looks over her shoulder as
she crosses to the other side of the
road implying that she's trying to
escape from someone after a while when
she reaches home her father comes out
and asks if everything is okay however
the girl simply runs right past him gets
into her car and drives away following
this she continues driving for hours
even during this time she keeps looking
behind as if someone is chasing her
finally she stops at a beach and calls
her family the girl frantically tells
them that she loves them a lot and that
they shouldn't worry about her after the
call she sits on the beach waiting for
something the next morning the girl is
found dead on the same spot her leg is
Twisted in a horrific act of violence
the next scene is set in another
Suburban neighborhood like any other Jay
a young girl is swimming in her backyard
pool her friends are watching a movie
inside but Jay doesn't seem interested
as she has to get ready for her date in
the evening she meets her date Hugh at a
movie theater as the two are waiting for
the show to begin Hugh spots a strange
woman in a yellow dress standing by the
entrance he quickly asks Jay if she can
see the woman but the latter says no
with this Hugh starts getting
uncomfortable and asks if they can leave
confused Jay asks for the reason but
Hugh simply makes an excuse that he
isn't feeling well with this the two
call it a night and depart the next
morning Jay is chatting with her friend
about the date she's clearly interested
in heal and expresses her desire to be
in a relationship with him that same
night they go out again they have dinner
at a restaurant and as the two are
talking a mysterious figure approaches
Hugh slowly later the couple goes to a
secluded place and has a romantic time
in Hugh's car however before Jay can put
her clothes back on she is suddenly
jumped by you from behind he chloroforms
her and knocks her unconscious the next
thing Jay knows she's tied to a
wheelchair in an abandoned parking lot
Hugh seems apologetic and Promises not
to hurt her he then reveals why he is
doing all this it it turns out a
mysterious entity is following him
around everywhere he goes it all started
when he had intercourse with a girl and
her curse was passed on to him he
further explains that the only way to
pass on the curse is to have intercourse
with someone else lastly he also
mentions that the entity can take the
form of anyone so one can never know if
it's real Jay obviously doesn't believe
him and starts screaming for help
however he Wheels her over to the edge
of the building and shows her The Entity
suddenly Jay spots a strange woman
completely unclothed slowly walking
towards her Hugh tells her that she has
to sleep with someone else to transfer
her curse but if the entity catches up
to her she will be killed following this
he drives her back to her friend's house
and drops her off he then flees the
place before someone catches him in no
time Jay's friends rush to help her they
call the cops and Jay has asked a few
questions about what happened the police
investigate but find no signs of Hugh as
the boy had been using a fake name the
next day at school while in class J note
this is an old woman in the distance she
seems really out of place only dressed
in a nightgown surprisingly no one else
in the class notices her as a result Jay
realizes that the woman is the entity
and freaks out she immediately grabs her
bag and leaves but in the hallway again
it encounters the same woman terrified
she runs away from the school and heads
to a store where her friends Kelly and
Paul work as expected her friends don't
believe any of it but Paul offers to
accompany her at her house that night
here we get to know that Paul has a
crush on Jay so he is willing to go to
any extent to be with her seeing his
courage everyone in the group agrees to
accompany Jay so that she feels safe
that night Jay struggles to sleep as she
has become paranoid she sneaks
downstairs and finds Paul watching a
movie he tries to comfort her saying
that everything will be all right but
she does not listen just then they hear
the kitchen window smash Paul goes to
look but sees nothing there scared he
then goes upstairs and wakes everyone
else meanwhile Jay is left alone
downstairs she decides to check kitchen
for herself to her horror she finds a
scarred woman limping towards her
creepily Jay rushes upstairs to her
friend's room and slams the door behind
her everyone tries to calm her down but
Jay has been left traumatized she
finally comes to terms with the fact
that she has been cursed but her friends
are still not convinced after a while
one of them decides to open the door
revealing an empty hallway Jay is
initially relieved thinking that she was
merely hallucinating but right then a
freakishly tall man comes walking in
behind her friend she screams and
immediately escapes at the bedroom
window and onto the balcony in the next
scene Jay reaches a local park on her
bike while her friends catch up and try
to calm her down seeing Jay getting
paranoid the group decides to track you
down so that they can get some answers
later the group finds his address and
reaches the place but it's abandoned not
willing to give up they then start
looking around and find old photos and
other clues that point them to Hughes
High School on reaching the school they
finally find his real address and
learned that his name is Jeff wasting no
time they arrive at his house and
confront him Jeff immediately apologizes
and explains that the same thing was
done to him after a one-night stand he
reveals that the curse is real and the
only way to escape is to pass it on
hearing this Jay and her friends are
stuck and they decide to get as far away
as they can they then begin listing out
potential locations and one of them
suggests a friend's lake house Jay loves
the idea and all of them decide to head
there as the days pass the group forgets
all their miseries and has the best time
of their lives at the lake house that is
until one day when a strange woman
approaches Jay from behind she is none
other than the entity of death the woman
grabs Jay by the hair leaving everyone
in a State of Shock Paul tries to save
his friend but since he cannot see the
entity he can't do much when he tries to
swing a chair randomly The Entity throws
him away after this the group runs into
a nearby shed Jay grabs a gun and shoots
at the entity but it does little to no
damage to it terrified she slams the
shed door and locks it surprisingly The
Entity bangs on the door and creates a
hole at the bottom Jay Waits and sees
nothing coming through and as she moves
closer to the hole she is startled by a
small boy with a marked face The Entity
has shifted its shape to fit inside the
hole Force Jay flees from the shed and
gets in her car she then drives away as
fast as she can but in a state of panic
she crashes into a cornfield in the next
scene Jay wakes up in the hospital with
all her friends by her side she's
injured slightly and learns from her
friends that she has to stay there for a
few days hearing this Jay starts
panicking again as she believes that the
entity will Corner her in the hospital
but her friends calm her down and assure
her that they will be by her side it is
at this moment that Jay realizes that
she can end all of this all she has to
do is have intercourse with someone and
pass on the curse luckily Greg agrees to
do it with her as he still doesn't
believe in the curse and wants her to
feel normal poor poor Greg that night
the two have a wonderful moment in the
hospital bed when later asked if it was
worth it Greg said yes sir absolutely a
few days later as Jay is watching over
Greg's house she notices someone
breaking in through his front window
surprised that she can still see the
entity Jay hurdley calls Greg to alert
him sadly there's no answer so she is
compelled to rush over to his house she
finds the entity upstairs disguised as
Greg's mother banging on his bedroom
door Jay tries her best to warn Greg but
the latter opens the door and suffers a
pain death terrified that she races out
of the house and drives away she knows
that the entity is now following her
again scared and shocked at what she
just witnessed she travels to the beach
as far away as she can get there she
sees some boys and tries to lure them to
have intercourse however she changes her
mind at the last moment and returns home
the following day Paul offers to help
Jay he confesses that he likes her and
mentions that he is willing to take the
curse if that's the only way to keep her
safe ah the men in this movie are so
bold however this time Jay refuses and
instead thinks of a plan to kill the
entity once and for all later the
surviving group of friends drive to a
nearby swimming pool and break in
they've brought with them various
electrical items that they intend to use
to shock the water Jay acts as bait and
waits in the pool for the entity after a
while she spots it walking in however
their plan backfires when the entity
starts throwing in the electrical items
into the pool it seems as if the entity
is an intelligent one expectedly Jay
starts panicking and she goes below the
water to dodge the attacks her friends
also scramble to help her but can't see
where the entity is meanwhile Paul takes
out a gun and tries to shoot it he is
Guided by Jay but accidentally ends up
shooting one of his friends in the leg
as the entity continues throwing objects
at Jay one of the friends cleverly
throws a blanket over it so that Paul
can see where it is he immediately
shoots the entity in the head causing it
to collapse in the pool believing that
they have finally succeeded in their
mission Jay proceeds to swim out of the
pool but the entity once again gets up
and grabs her foot it tries to drag her
underneath the water and drown her but
fortunately the heroic Paul aims at the
entity and shoots it multiple times
causing it to finally let go of Jay this
makes the group assume that they have
finally killed the entity but to their
horror the pool starts getting filled
with a strange red liquid The Entity is
nowhere to be seen and their plan has
failed once again realizing that it
cannot be killed Jay changes her mind
and sleeps with Paul that night poor
poor Paulie with this the curse has been
transferred to him in the final scene of
the movie Paul wanders around town
looking for the perfect person to pass
the curse on to he sees two hookers and
briefly stops his car to interact with
them this movie is an all-time classic
it's a shame that it didn't have a
better ending
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching